-We're back with Nick Kroll.
And I want to ask about
the p'dcast,
because this is not just for
fans of "Oh, hello."
You delve into a
historical moment in time,
the life and times of
Princess Di.
-Yeah, George and Gil
felt like Princess Diana,
who died 21 years ago in tha
fateful car wreck in Paris -
George and Gil
felt like there had not been
enough podcasts, books,
television programs,
magazine articles about
Princess Di,
the life and death of
Princess Diana,
and the royals in general.
-Hardly ever mentioned.
Hardly ever mentioned.
-And so they felt like
it was a good time to --
21 years ago not to the day,
it felt like a good time
for them to dig in deeper.
And they brought in
Ira Glass and Sarah Koenig
from "This American Life"
and "Serial,"
and John Oliver,
and Pete Davidson, of course
-Now, that's interesting.
I do want to -- Because at least
John Oliver is British,
so he might be able to
shed some light.
What light did you find that
Pete Davidson was able to shine?
Or I should say, you know --
Yeah, that Gil and George foun
that Pete Davidson
could shine on it.
-Well, ironically,
you would wonder like,
"What does a 26-year-old kid
from Staten Island,
who truly had no idea how
Princess Diana died
or that she died at all or
really knew anything about her
to begin with?
But what Pete
did bring to the table
was what it was like to
be hounded by the paparazzi.
-Ah!
-In a weird way,
Pete was, in fact,
the most useful guest
on the podcast
to give a sense of what it was
like for Princess Diana,
because, you know,
I would say that
"Saturday Night Live" --
And I know you're
a former cast member and writer,
but they're kind of our royalty.
And when I think
about "Saturday Night Live
and royalty, I think about you
because you're
obviously the king.
And you wouldn't say this, but I
think it's obvious.
I've seen in writing you're th
king of "Saturday Night Live."
-Thank you.
-And you're the
king of my heart.
And -- Are you in
the attic right now?
Where are you?
-I am in an attic right now,
yeah.
-So your wife and kids are
downstairs, so you're alone?
-Two floors --
No, they're like --
Yeah, they're like
two floors down, yeah.
-And my girlfriend
is upstairs, so...
-Right, but they might --
You know, the kids
wander up all the time.
-But isn't that what's
kind of exciting?
-Hey, we're running a little -
Do you want to plug anything
before we go?
What is that tumbler
you're drinking out of?
-Oh, this is also -- This is a
tumbler also from --
This tumbler came as a set fro
"Snowpiercer" on TNT.
-"Snowpiercer" on TNT.
Daveed Diggs.
-Yes. It's a great cast.
And that's a tumbler, the
"W" from the show.
-Is it the "W" from "snow"
-Yes. It's also the W Hotel.
I also would love to
plug the W Hotel
on Hollywood and Vine.
-Great.
-Right now, not o-- And really
the W Hotels around the world.
It's a great time.
-The most white leather, I
think, of any hotel in America
is -- A W Hotel will have
the most white leather.
-Yes. You can always count o
bottle service in the lobby.
You can count on
anything you want.
Whatever city you're in,
if you want to meet some
of the more annoying peopl
in that city,
go to the W Hotel lobby
wherever you are.
So I want to shout out the
W Hotel chain.
Great time to travel.
I also want to quickly, do
genuinely want to shout ou
I am on Taika Waititi
and friends
reading "James
and the Giant Peach."
-Great.
-Roald Dahl's estate
gave them permission
and are doing a bunch
of donations through that.
So, it's me and Taika
and all of our friends,
the Hemsworth brothers,
Meryl Streep.
-Close friends.
-Benedict Cumberbatch,
all of us.
You know the crew.
-Yeah. The crew.
-I want you to meet them, Seth
I want...
-I would love to
make that happen.
But we are -- I am going to sa
goodbye for now.
And please, please listen to
"Oh, Hello: the P'dcast"
and watch "Big Mouth" on Netflix
and "Snowpiercer" on TNT.
-And, Seth,
just personally with you,
I would like to promote
my body to you.
-Okay. Well, you are my friend
and I love you very much.
-I love you, too.
-I'll see you when this is over.